votre excellence louise bessette c'est
avec beaucoup d'émotion que louise
bessette est allé chercher son prix de
la musique classique remis par la
gouverneure générale du canada un très
grand honneur pour l'artiste c'est la
plus haute distinction qu'un artiste
canadien peut recevoir et ce qui est
vraiment très spécial aussi c'est que
c'est un prix pour l'ensemble de la
carrière
[Musique]
et quelle carrière depuis plus de 30 ans
louise bessette sillonne le monde entier
pour jouer les plus grands compositeurs
classiques bien sûr mais aussi et
surtout faire découvrir les oeuvres
d'artistes contemporains du xxème et
xxième siècle moins connue du grand
public elle est reconnue mondialement
pour être l'interprète de ses
compositeurs notamment du français
olivier messiaen dont elle est la
spécialiste au canada oui je suis une de
celles qui portent le flambeau j'ai reçu
plusieurs prix grâce à la musique
d'olivier messiaen
[Musique]
c'est vraiment un compositeur qui tient
une place immense dans ma route
louise bessette entretient des relations
privilégiées avec ses compositeurs
contemporains beaucoup de compositeurs
ont écrit pour moi moi c'est toujours un
bonheur et une fierté de partir en
tournée et d'avoir la musique de nos
compositeurs canadiens dans mes bagages
louise bessette a commencé à apprendre
le piano à l'âge de 5 ans mais c'est à
l'adolescence qu'elle sait vraiment
lancer dans cette carrière de pianiste
en remportant concours sur concours
depuis elle a enregistré une vingtaine
d'albums et enchaîner récitals concerts
et projets spéciaux
seul sur scène en formation de musique
de chambre ou avec orchestre symphonique
j'aime vraiment vraiment les trois
volets
de ma carrière et puis je crois que
chaque volet nourrit de l'autre et je
trouve ça tellement beau je me sens
toujours privilégié d'être là dans des
endroits magnifiques avec des pianos
magnifique avec un public extraordinaire
et puis alors c'est pour moi c'est
toujours des grands moments
à l'aube de ses 60 ans cette pianiste
exceptionnel qui enseigne aussi son art
au conservatoire de musique de montréal
n'a qu'un rêve poursuivre cette belle
route le plus longtemps possible
[Musique]
ici catherine françois radio canada
montréal